Logos are everywhere.
They're a huge part of daily life,
from the toothpaste
we use in the morning,
the insoles of our shoes,
cereal packaging,
phone apps -
most of the products we see and use
are branded with some form
of symbol or wordmark.
Why is that?
Logos aren't just a label
that shows who's responsible
for a product or service,
they're also used because
people often choose products
based on their perceived value
rather than their actual value.
Think of the celebrity who drives
an Aston Martin instead of say,
a Skoda.
Skoda has often been ranked Car of
the Year in many European countries
and delivers much better mileage
at one tenth of the price.
It's the logical choice.
But it's Aston Martin's identity that
creates images of luxury and status
and that is what usually
clinches the sale.
A logo can appear in various formats
depending on both the brand
and the environment
in which the logo is displayed.
Wordmarks are type-based logos
that draw attention to
a brand name on its own.
The type design often
gets a custom twist
to capture the essence
of what the brand does
and to separate it from competitors.
That could be the loose, flowing feel
of Cadbury's or Coca Cola
or the more traditional vibe
of The New York Times
and The Washington Post.
Visual tricks such as
the use of negative space
can be applied to add
little design magic.
An example is the hidden FedEx arrow
that conveys direction and movement.
Monograms are shortened wordmarks
that are usually initials
of longer names.
These are about turning
a mouthful into something
that's generally easier to remember.
Another form a logo can take
is that of a graphic symbol.
Still representing the core
of a brand's service,
it's often used where space
is at a premium -
like an avatar,
or that little area
beside a website URL.
Sometimes when a brand
is so established
and the symbol is
instantly recognisable
anything else
becomes almost unnecessary.
Symbols are particularly well suited
for incorporating subtle messages
that act as talking points
and heighten memorability.
The bear in the Toblerone logo
is one example -
it adds meaning because the bear
relates to an old coat of arms
that represents the town
where the Toblerone chocolate
was originally created.
The main job of a logo
is to identify.
It takes its meaning
from the entity it represents
not the other way around.
This is why, when logos
first enter the world,
they're essentially empty vessels.
With consistent use over time
the mark gets filled with every
association people have
with a particular brand,
whether that's positive, negative
or something in between.
That's exactly how
religious symbols work.
There's nothing inherent
in the shapes,
but it's about what those shapes
have come to represent
in the minds of the people
who are looking at them.
Another form of logo
is that of a combination mark -
essentially a wordmark
and symbol together.
This lets you communicate messages
in a slightly different way.
Look at how the Amazon logo
has it all from A to Z
and even adds a little smile
into the mix.
So how can you tell
a good logo from bad?
In my work as a designer
I judge the strength of an idea
on the following criteria -
By appropriate I mean
the design needs to be relevant
in shape and form
to the client in question.
For example, a logo for a toy maker
may need to be fun
and appealing to kids
or a logo for a car racing team
may need to appear sleek and dynamic.
By simple I mean that the design
can't say too much.
It should tell one story
so it's adaptable enough
for use in all applications
from on a billboard
or the side of the building
to a social media avatar
or a website favicon.
By memorable I mean that the design
also needs to be distinctive -
unusual enough to be remembered.
A good way of testing this is to
describe the design to someone
and see if they can sketch
a fairly accurate likeness.
Some of my favourite logos
aren't particularly well-known
but they've stuck with me because
they all share those same traits.
Telling a relevant story
with simplicity and distinction.